today on the matt walsh show donald
trump is impeached for the second time
i'm sure you've heard we'll have some
analysis about that and five headlines
including
another elementary school indoctrinating
children into radical
left-wing racial and sexual theories but
this again is an elementary school now
where they're doing it and in our daily
cancellation we'll discuss the
apparently
extremely important story of the
so-called soho karen
it's a woman who made headlines for
weeks after accosting a black teenager
over her missing
missing cell phone the media thinks this
is a very important story
and we'll talk about why all that and
much more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
well if we've learned anything over the
last week i think it's that
you need you need to be using a vpn i
think that's one thing we can take from
this um
censorship on social media uh has as we
know over the last week
it's been bad for a long time only
getting worse and uh but over the last
week we've seen it we've seen it
um worse than ever we've seen it ramped
up to a level that uh
that we had not seen before twitter and
facebook though are supposed to be open
platforms i don't need their content
moderators acting like the op-ed section
the new york times
but that's what they do so instead of
letting social media sites revoke your
right to free speech how about revoking
their right
to your data which they have no right to
to begin with now you could
just deactivate all your social media
accounts if you want to but that would
be giving the left just what they
just what they want which is to chase
you out of the public
sphere off the public stage out of the
discussion
that's i don't think that's the right
move that's why i use
expressvpn ever wonder how free to
access sites like facebook
make all their money well they do it by
tracking your searches video history and
everything you click on
and then selling all of your valuable
data that's how they do it when you use
expressvpn
you make yourself anonymous so that your
online presence
is um is is hidden and uh and
that makes your activity more difficult
to trace and more difficult to sell to
advertisers
and that just gives you privacy that you
deserve because just because you're
online
that doesn't give someone the right to
take all your data and sell it
expressvpn
couldn't be easier to set up you just
tap one button on your phone or computer
and you're protected so if you're able
to just tap a button then you can use
expressvpn
also encrypts 100 of your data to
protect you from hackers and internet
bad guys
it's finally time to say no to
censorship and take back your online
privacy at expressvpn
by visiting my special link you'll get
an extra three months of expressvpn
service for free again that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh expressvpn.com walsh to protect
your data today so the year is 2059
donald trump has just been posthumously
impeached
marking his 40th impeachment overall in
what has become a sacred annual ritual
as trump is no longer there to stand
trial a goat is brought in to be his
symbolic replacement after conviction
the goat is ceremonially
uh disembodied and uh and disemboweled
and sacrificed by house speaker and high
priestess
nancy pelosi still maintaining her
leadership position despite being
about 132 years old by now this is only
a
very slightly exaggerated look into the
future in the non-exaggerated present
the democrats have impeached donald
trump for the second time in a little
over a year it took congress about
244 years to impeach a president two
times
so about 244 years we had congress
impeaching two presidents
one each so that's two total um the
democrats
doubled that number in 13 months and now
that mitch mcconnell
has announced that he will not call the
senate back in session for trial the
democrats will also be the first to try
to convict and remove a president
who's already left office they're going
to run into the logistical problem when
they try to remove him
of him not being there to remove now
there's controversy over whether this
is legal to do in the first place though
it seems to me unlikely that it is
um and whether it's whether it's legal
or not it's
it certainly is certain that it's an
absurd thing to attempt to do in any
case
but these democrats just cannot pass up
an opportunity for political theatrics
speaking of theatrics uh here's nancy
pelosi
on the house floor yesterday making her
little stump speech here it is watch
i stand before you as a wife a mother a
grandmother
a daughter a daughter whose father
proudly
serves in this congress i just wanted to
note there
the gendered language has been banned
by her own rules but exceptions can be
made apparently so that female
politicians can identify themselves as
a wife and mother before going on to
make a point that has
nothing to do with the fact that they
are wives and mothers
i love them politicians do that i'm a
wife and mothers okay what does that
have to do with anything
really i'm disappointed that they their
commitment to genderless language isn't
more serious you know i was looking
forward to
hearing about the impeachment of donald
trump
meanwhile one of the newest members of
the squad and making a strong push to be
crowned
the most obnoxious i would say is corey
bush representative cory bush
and she had this to say listen if we
fail to remove a white supremacist
president who incited a white
supremacist insurrection
it's communities like missouri's first
district that suffer the most
the 117th congress must understand that
we have a mandate
to legislate in defense of black lives
the first step in that process is to
root out
white supremacy starting with impeaching
the white supremacist
in chief you know it's hardly noticeable
or notable anymore when they do it but
still we should take
we should take note of the fact uh of of
how democrats have just
casually and in such a perfunctory way
turn the capitol hill riot into a racist
event
because of course they're going to do
that even though race had absolutely
nothing to do with it
there are in fact many ways to condemn
something without calling it racist
but the belief on the left now is that
anything that is bad
must also be racist if it's bad it's
racist
also most of the things that aren't bad
must also be racist
for her part maxine waters played a
similar race card but she took it even
further than that
listen this president is headed toward a
civil war
and we're the object of their hate and
so it is not only about protection
and security for the capital and us we
need to talk about
what we're going to do to force
diversity and
inclusion and protection for our
communities
yes the remedy for rioting is to quote
forced diversity and inclusion
don't ask maxine waters what she means
by that because she clearly has no idea
all she knows is that it seems is is
that conservatives are
an apocalyptic threat to the united
states and president trump is going to
lead them
like a warlord into a civil war if
maxine's goal here
with her little rant there was to
provide a great example of what
incitement
actually sounds like then she succeeded
brilliantly
because that's the irony of it as the
democrats impeach
trump over incitement much of what they
have said in the process of impeaching
him
is far more inciting than anything trump
said last wednesday
but here's the central question why did
the democrats do this what's the point
of all this
we already touched on one point
political theatrics showmanship the
spectacle of false bravery
standing up to the fascist dictator and
all that also general contempt for him
and for his voters
um no those are the obvious things many
other things went into it as well but
let me suggest another
if if i'm going to get really
psychological here
let me suggest another perhaps slightly
deeper motivation
and i think it's this the democrats
don't know how to quit
donald trump this is in its way
a romance not the kind of love affair
that you'd read about in a romance novel
but
not too far off they're setting it up so
that they can continue railing against
donald trump even
after he's left office he's been the
center of their political and
ideological world for so long they've
defined themselves
by their opposition to him he's been the
object of nearly
all of their attention think about that
for five years
he has been everything they have defined
themselves and their
their agenda by him
and they can't stand to lose him they
hate him but they can't stand to lose
him
they need him he has their identity
their purpose
the wind beneath their wings this is
especially true of the media which has
spent thousands and thousands and
thousands of hours
talking about trump and now will have
great gaping holes in their programming
to fill holes that will be even harder
to fill now because
they're going to have to ignore any
scandals or controversies that come out
of the next administration
so we're not going to have that to talk
about either this is the quandary that
the left finds itself in
one familiar to anybody who's been in a
co-dependent relationship
they want out but they're scared of
leaving
and it's not just them in fairness the
political and cultural universe has
revolved around trump for for
everybody every issue has been distilled
down to trump
and a lot of that has to do with the
media that's the media's doing
or everything begins and ends with
donald trump
but it's not supposed to be this way in
america we're not supposed to
talk so much about the president or care
so much about him
in times past and you probably have to
go back to before the advent of cable
news
for this but in times past people went
weeks or months even longer without
thinking about the president at all they
weren't inundated
with news about him every day they
didn't live in an ecosphere that was so
saturated with his presence
presidents were not omnipresent
for most of american history
so people had political and cultural
identities that were not defined by the
president not defined by
one man one politician and i would say
it was it was better that way
a lot of other things may not have been
better in those times but
that piece of it certainly was and that
would be the one silver lining going
forward
that we can talk about something else
for a change it may seem small
maybe it is but it's not nothing can
think about something else
of course the problem is that the trump
obsession will be replaced by something
else
probably not a biden obsession he's not
quite he doesn't quite have the flare to
attract that sort of devotion
either in a negative or positive way but
there will be something or someone or a
series of somethings and someone's that
the media dangles in front of us to keep
us from
getting down to the heart of the matter
and discussing important issues on a
deeper level
but hopefully after this experience
we can be on guard against that in the
future
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
well a lot of you been leaving comments
i've seen a ton of them uh asking
when the andrew clavin show is going to
be back that's a question that that a
lot of us have
well i've got good good news starting
tomorrow january 15th andrew clavin is
back
with a new weekly program every friday
it'll be treated to a 90-minute show in
which andrew will wrap up the week's
events
talk to special guests and give you his
unique insights into what's really going
on
i think we all really want to hear what
he has to say especially about this week
make sure you're subscribed to his show
so you can stay up to date to on
all the new episodes you know i really
hate that it's become so uh
common for people to make up stories
about their
things that their kids said to them you
know or in camila harris's case to make
up stories about things they said as
kids
and this genre is used normally in a
political context to prove a point
like i guarantee you could go on twitter
right now there are probably a bunch of
tweets
of people talking about their alleged
six-year-old who who heard the news
about trump's second impeachment and had
some really insightful thing to say
but the reason i hate this is that kids
actually do say
hilarious and oddly insightful things
all the time you know anyone who's a
parent knows
your kid's capable of saying some really
great things but you can't share it
anymore publicly because of this veil of
suspicion that will
that will that will cover it uh because
it will sound like you made it up
because that's what everybody does
so for example the reason i bring this
up is um here's a real thing my son
actually said to me
last night i took my the two boys out
for ice cream and on the way home
we were talking and he was sharing with
me how he had
burped loudly earlier in the day and
made his sister cry
because she was so disturbed by the by
the burp which
you know some things you had to stifle
after on as a parent but then my son
says
there's a direct quote he says girls
will never understand the ways of men
it's my seven-year-old son who said that
direct quote
where did that come from i don't know
kids just say stuff
and really they say so much stuff
they're just constantly talking that
eventually they'll stumble on something
like that
on a little morsel of brilliance
um and quite poignant i thought girls
will never understand the ways of men
very well put though i confess
uh the reverse is probably even more
even more true
than that all right let's go to number
one um a
virginia school district is considering
a slew of progressive icons as
candidates this is from the washington
free beacon by the way
uh considering a slew of progressive
icons as candidates have become the new
namesake of t.c williams high school
who's if you remember if you if that
name sounds familiar that's the high
school that was uh featured in
remember the titans in on november 20
in november of 2020 the alexandria city
uh public schools board
unanimously voted to change the school's
name because its namesake thomas
chambliss uh
williams was a segregationist community
activists initiated calls for a name
change following the death of george
floyd at the hanson police
now the district introduced a poll
and by the way this is this is not the
first school district or the only school
district in virginia right now that's
contemplating name changes we talked a
few weeks ago
there's a school school district getting
rid of thomas jefferson thomas jefferson
high school's out the window
they're going to think of some new name
to put there so here are um
among the choices uh
camila harris high school so she hasn't
done anything yet but already she's
going to get her own
name it's kind of like the barack obama
gets a nobel prize
system or before he had done anything he
still gets the prize so camille harris
already gets the
already gets the high schools named
after has done absolutely nothing
so camilla harris high school meghan
markle high school
and also george floyd memorial high
school
that is being considered and i wish i
could say that there's no way they
actually choose this one
but given the state of things i would
have no such confidence
george floyd who's the the only
distinction about this man's life is
that he was that he
he died at the hands of police um that's
the only distinction
other than that he was a violent felon
forced his way into a woman's home put a
gun to her stomach and robbed her in
front of her kid
like that's that's the other major event
from his life
that and he was any and he died while
being arrested
gonna get his own high school uh and
then i'm looking through some of the
other choices
somehow george washington is is an
option george washington high school
so maybe they can rename it to george
washington and then a year from now
take his name off because he was a slave
owner just keep it going
um diversity high school is another
option
so hercules high school a lot of options
here
some of them not terrible ruth bader
ginsburg of course
on there as well all right number two
mayor bill de blasio went on the news
yesterday and he had a big announcement
a big and brave and bold announcement to
make
and here it is listen mika uh here to
announce that the city of new york
is severing all contracts with the trump
organization
our legal team has done an assessment
and the contracts make very clear
if a company the leadership of that
company is engaged in criminal activity
we have the right to sever the contract
uh
inciting an insurrection let's be clear
let's say these words again inciting an
insurrection against the united states
government
clearly constitutes criminal activity so
the city of new york will no longer have
anything to do with the
trump organization
okay that now the trump organization is
guilty of inciting a riot not just trump
himself
this is especially rich coming from bill
de blasio
uh of all people who did more than
almost any
any other mayor in encouraging and
legitimizing and romanticizing the blm
riots
uh but he didn't do quite as much as
mayor ted wheeler of portland
and since we're on the subject of
feckless mayors here's an interesting
moment with ted wheeler again mayor of
portland uh let's watch this
just three weeks ago protesters broke
into the oregon state capitol i have
heard people at these protests elsewhere
saying well they let it happen in
portland so why not do it here
it seems in some way the actions of
these small groups that you're referring
to
have set the stage for what has happened
on a state level and potentially a
national level i know you said
it will take time to crack down on these
groups but do we have that time
are you blaming me for what happened at
the u.s capitol i i don't buy that
are you blaming me are you are you
saying i could be a response i could
have something to do with it is that
what you're suggesting
uh yeah that's what i'm suggesting ted i
don't know if that's what she was
suggesting but
that's what i'm suggesting you certainly
have something to do with it
this is what happens when you give
people the idea that writing is
not it's it's a really important facet
of this
not just that writing is uh that it's
okay
you know that's the message that we've
gotten from ted wheeler and many others
on the left
but also that it works because on the
left when they rioted
they got what they want
now you might say the cost
to them was not worth the price at least
the cost of them ideologically because
at the same time did they scare a lot of
other people away who are sort of in the
middle who
see the writing and defund the police
and you know are they scared away from
the from the left now
that's a question but in terms of
affecting policies and that sort of
thing
yeah they they got what they want they
got they got utter and total
capitulation from people like ted
wheeler
now on the right that's that's not how
it works
right so with with with the the capitol
hill rioters what what has happened what
has happened
since then um donald trump is impeached
uh d-platformed
thousands of of uh conservatives banned
from social media entire conservative
social media
apps taken down um not to mention
people died and dozens of arrests
so that's what happens when
conservatives do it
and that's that's also something that
that i think conservatives have to keep
in mind with we have to live in reality
and you know we shouldn't be riding
because it's it's wrong in the first
place whether it works or not you
shouldn't be doing it
but it's also something conservatives
should remember when they say well the
left does this
and so we can do it
yeah but two things number one doesn't
make it right number two uh
we we live we don't we don't live
in the same universe as them that's just
the reality that's the reality of the
situation
they they own the system we don't
so if you go and riot you're not gonna
get
utter in total capitulation from from
from your leaders and politicians people
that rule over you you're not going to
get it
they'll get it you won't that's just the
reality and i'm a big fan of operating
within reality
i'm a big fan of that all right number
three i just want to read this headline
headline from the wall street journal
um pope francis says women can read at
mass
as debate on women clergy continues you
see these things throughout throughout
his pontiff we've seen headlines like
this and i always enjoy them as a
catholic
where we're told the media tells us that
pope francis has made this revolutionary
radical step
and as a catholic you read it and you
say well no it's what do you mean it's
it's been like that for a long time
i can tell you right now if you've seen
this headline women have been reading in
catholic masses
for decades i mean my whole life as i've
seen this and
goes back even further than that uh so
this is
this is not news at all so pope francis
has said that women
can keep doing the thing that they
already were doing
big news there all right um christopher
ruffo who we've
we've followed he works for the the city
journal we followed his reporting
um he reports on a lot of the the
brainwashing especially the critical
race theory brainwashing in public
schools
and here's his latest thread this is on
twitter he says
a cupertino elementary school forces
third graders to deconstruct their
racial and sexual identities
then rank themselves according to their
power and privilege
just to highlight again this is an
elementary school okay not a high school
not that it's okay in a high school but
even worse the younger they get um he
says i've obtained exclusive
whistleblower documents from inside the
classroom
they will shock you we'll read through
some of this it says first the teacher
told the eight and nine-year-old
students that they live in a dominant
culture
of white middle-class cis-gendered
educated able-bodied christians
who created and maintain this culture in
order to hold power and stay in power
this to a bunch of eight-year-olds and
the eight-year-olds are just sitting
there
this this is why this stuff is so is so
evil and infuriating
because the six-year-olds are just
sitting there soaking this in they have
no idea what's being
said when an eight-year-old hears this
all they can say is
okay if you say so
they do not have the information the
knowledge the critical thinking skills
and it's no knock on them it's just
they they just don't have it to analyze
this stuff
reading going back to the his his thread
says reading from
this book is anti-racist the teacher
taught the children
the theory of intersectionality and
claim that those with privilege have
power over others
and that folks by the way folks f-o-l-x
that is the genderless way of saying
folks
because somehow ks is gendered
replace it with an x and it's okay maybe
you've learned that by now
you know all existing words are
offensive because they already exist
if you want to make them non-offensive
just put x just randomly throw an x in
there somewhere
folks who do not benefit from their
social identities have little to no
privilege and power the teacher asked
students to create an identity map
listing their race gender class religion
family structure and
other characteristics they were told to
circle the identities that hold power
and privilege
in a related assignment the children
were asked to write short essays
describing which aspects of their
identities hold power and privilege
and which are oppressed in effect
ranking themselves according to their
intersectionality
hierarchy okay so you so certain parts
of your identity can have power
and certain parts could be oppressed is
that how it works
so you can so you can you can oppress
yourself i guess
because if the people that are the
oppressors so you have oppressors and
you have the oppressed
well now according to this parts of your
identity can belong to either group
now i'm assuming i haven't read the uh i
haven't i haven't looked through all of
the
powerpoint slides yet but i'm assuming
for example a white woman
probably classic example of somebody
oppressing themselves
because you're white so you got the
oppressor role covered but you're also a
woman so you're oppressed
oppressing yourself this is not
schizophrenic or insane at all
parents at the school were scandalized
they were basically teaching racism to
my eight-year-old said one parent who
rallied a half dozen families to protest
the curriculum and demanded a meeting
with the principal
um and then
it details some of the other parents and
their reaction to it okay
all i can say with this sort of thing is
i mean it's the same thing i always say
and i can only repeat myself that's all
i can do
get your kids out of the public school
system this
i i cannot stress enough this is not
going to get better
it will not and if you're in a school
right now
or if your kids are in school where this
isn't happening first of all how do you
know it's not happening
you only think it's not happening could
be um
because your kid is not even is not even
telling you like 10 of the things that
happened in a school day
if you remember when you were a kid you
didn't
uh so but if your kid is in school this
isn't happening
eventually it will happen it will
no way around it this is what the public
school
school system exists for
to indoctrinate children into the
overarching the dominant dogmas and
doctrines of the day
didn't mean to go for the alliteration
there but there it is so get your kids
out of the public school system there
are other options
i'm not saying everybody can homeschool
but they're they're we got to start
getting creative about
about um solving these problems about
the way we educate our children
the system relies on you just sending
your kids there by default
because it's the easy thing to do it's
the automatic thing to do it's what it's
what you did as a kid it's just what
you're supposed to do
the system relies on that so we have to
break free from that way of thinking
come up with creative solutions
number five also this is uh what is this
from this from the new york post it says
experts have been left astonished after
a supermassive black hole which was
thought to be in the middle of a distant
galaxy has gone missing
the bright cluster galaxy a2261
one of my favorites appears to have uh
lost its black hole and some scientists
think it could now be floating through
space all right so that's that's here's
another thing we can worry about
apparently black holes can just become
dislodged from their location in space
and just float
just float away that's that's the next
thing would have i mean i i i couldn't
say i would object that much
if they told us that a black hole was
floating towards earth
i think our reaction first all be well
of course it is of course the black hole
is coming
put us out of our misery um so there's a
missing black hole
obviously my question is where where
were where were you when you last had it
that's the classic response from any
parent when a kid is missing something
actually my mom's a classic advice
anytime i was i couldn't find something
she said
well did you clean up your room did you
lift up all the dirty laundry on the
floor and look under that
and the thing that always annoyed me is
that 95 of the time
it was under the dirty laundry in my
room
i don't know if the black hole will be
but just a good tip in general
so i can tell you with clothing the two
things i'm looking for probably same as
you uh i want
comfort but i also want style and i want
it to be really easy on me because i'm
not the most i'm not the most stylish
guy myself
maybe you've noticed uh that's why i
want clothing that just looks great
makes it easy for me i can be confident
that when i put it on i'm gonna look
great and that's why i love mac welding
i can tell you there are a lot of things
that you'd probably like to leave behind
in 2020 well the most important being
your old underwear drawer if you're
rolling into 20 into the new year with
the same
bunching chafing and uncomfortable
underwear that you've uh
you've had for years now then you've got
to check out mack weldon
your wife will thank you as well i think
if you do mac weldon is an essential
piece of my daily routine
and they've got tons of stuff they've
got all the men's basics
socks shirts hoodies underwear polos
active shorts
and there's also versatility that comes
with mac welding because you're gonna
look great and you're gonna feel great
at the same time from working out
going out going to work going on a date
whatever you're doing
mack weldon has clothing for you because
it's for everyday life
and if you if you really want to get
bang for your buck
try out weldon blue it's a totally free
loyalty program level one gets you free
shipping for life once you reach level
two
by spending only two hundred dollars you
get twenty percent off every order for
the next year
so that's a lot of extra benefits and at
the same time like i said you're just
gonna look great on top of it so for
twenty percent off your first order
visit macweldon.com
walsh and enter promo code walls that's
macweldon.com
walsh promo code walls for 20 off mac
weldon
men's basics and also um tonight
is a big big night for the daily wire
we're very excited about it tonight
daily wire makes its entrance into
entertainment content with our first
feature film
run hide fight a lot of anticipation
leading up to this well you could
finally see the film tonight at 7 pm
eastern 4 p.m pacific
we're going to air a virtual premiere of
the movie in a in a special episode of
backstage which will stream live over at
daily wire website mobile and streaming
apps
as well as our youtube channel tonight's
event is free for everybody to watch
whether you're a member or not but after
the live stream is over the movie will
be available exclusively to daily wire
members so if you don't think you can
make
you'll be ever you'll be able to make it
for the the live stream event
then become a daily wire member and you
can watch it anytime please be aware
this film is not political
uh but it is intense and it's for mature
audiences only this is not a
family film this is not a film a movie
for kids
starring isabelle may thomas jane and
radha mitchell
run hide fight follows zoe hall who's a
high school student coping with the
recent loss of her mother
all she wants is to get through the last
few weeks of her senior year and leave
for college with his fresh start
instead her high school is attacked by
four nihilistic gun-toting students
who plan to take the siege um to make
their stage the worst school shooting in
history
but using her wits and survival skills
zoe fights back
to save her um her fellow students and
herself just a great
it's a very exciting film and we're
excited to bring it bring it to you and
bring you other great stories as well
that hollywood refuses to tell and we
hope you'll join us for tonight's event
again that's 7 p.m eastern 4 pm pacific
at dailywire.com
apple tv or roku or the daily wire
youtube channel we can't wait to bring
it to you
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today for our daily cancellation we
start with a quandary what do you do
when you want to convince people that
america is a racist country but america
stubbornly refuses to provide you with
enough legitimate examples to prove your
point
this is a problem that leftists and race
hustlers run into on a daily basis and
they've innovated several different ways
to deal with it one
is to of course invent racist hate
crimes out of whole cloth telling fables
about bleach wielding white supremacists
shouting maga country in chicago and so
forth
the other is to wildly misinterpret
actual statements or events to fit into
the desired racism mold
in the most extreme cases a garage door
pull maybe
labeled a noose and handed over to the
fbi for investigation
these are tried and true but not nearly
as cynically brilliant or effective as
the third
method which is to take a potential
example of real but isolated racism or
racial profiling
and treat it like pearl harbor blow it
up into a national crisis
and draw all sorts of broad and sweeping
conclusions from it
and that third strategy brings us to the
story of the so-called
soho karen real name mia pancetto now
pancetto achieved
national notoriety a couple weeks ago
after accosting a 14 year old black teen
son of a musician named keon harold
and falsely accusing him of stealing her
cell phone he didn't really steal it but
she accused him of it
the altercation which was caught on
video by harold unfolded in the lobby of
the arlo hotel in new york city
poncetto mostly ranted like a crazy
person before grabbing the teen
and um actually tackling him to the
ground
uh the video quickly went viral and
pancetto with her
new soho karen moniker became infamous
across the nation
the media conducted extensive
investigations and published lengthy
reports revealing pancetto's
past criminal record her dui arrests
um the vandalism of her airbnb apartment
on the morning of her confrontation of
the cell phone she apparently
smashed her door with a with a with a
fire extinguisher i believe
now it's clear that pancetta was firmly
in the wrong
it's possible that she racially profiled
the young man though it seems
it seems even more likely or at least
just as likely that she's simply an
unstable woman
who has acted this way towards many
people in her life with no regard to
their race or ethnicity i mean she
smashed her door
with with a fire extinguisher right
before this
so maybe an equal opportunity lunatic
you might say
but what's not clear in any case is why
this deranged behavior by a random woman
in a hotel lobby
needs to be the subject of national
discussion but the national discussion
ensued anyway helped along by the likes
of al
sharpton and the ubiquitous ambulance
chasing lawyer benjamin crump
though there were no ambulances or
injuries reported in this case but
benjamin crump is always on the scene
now
and they both sort of rappelled down as
though from helicopters hovering above
to conduct a press conference with the
boy's parents and presumably to get a
piece of any forthcoming lawsuits
the parents claim that their son's life
was put in danger
and they found reason somehow to blame
the hotel where the assault happened
arguing that the business is culpable
for the arbitrary outbursts of any
troubled woman who
happens to wander into their lobby they
even had a nifty refrain they kept
repeating ready-made for t-shirts and
posters
calling on the hotel to check out from
racism
check out because it's a hotel get it
that's the yeah very clever
uh let's let's listen to a little bit of
this news report about the case
keon harold junior's parents say they're
still traumatized by the attack on their
son
they want everyone involved to be held
accountable this racial profiling thing
is real you don't have to say the n word
to act in a racist way the arlo looked
right over my son
the incident took place at the arlo
hotel in soho last month
surveillance video appears to show this
woman 22 old mia poncero tackled
14-year-old keon harold jr after
accusing him
of stealing her cell phone no i'm not
letting him walk away with my phone
the manager of the hotel approaches the
boy and asked to see the phone
which he does not have check out time
check
checkout time the family is now asking
for people to boycott the business
and its parent company unless they put
an end to what they call
racial profiling all the hotel is just
as responsible
as this soho caring and we're going to
check out if they don't check step up
the arlo hotel has apologized for the
incident
and says the manager did call police
regarding ponsero's conduct
check out if they don't step up they got
the poster boards ready they're
boycotting the family
the uh the the parent company they're
accusing
the the the hotel and the parent company
of racial profiling
they didn't do it wasn't their fault i
mean
you know maybe again you know if it were
me
and and i was walking out of hotel and
some crazy woman came up accused me of
stealing her cell phone and started
it was draped all over me trying to
tackle me to the ground
um i would uh i would i would get her
off of me
i would call the police because she's
crazy and that's illegal that is assault
um and then i'd probably just go about
my day you know i would probably just go
home and it would be it would be a funny
story i would tell
my wife and you know for probably from
then on out it's a story i would tell
periodically but
i just can't imagine holding a press
conference about it a press conference
about that
now for all the talk of systemic racism
and law enforcement
the nypd certainly expended more time
and resources on this case than they
would on almost
any other similar case of a random
weirdo accosting somebody in public
detectives tracked pancetto all the way
back to california
and brought her to california to new
york to stand trial
she was hit with four felonies in the
case attempted robbery endangering the
welfare of a child
attempted grand larceny and attempted
assault
again poncetta's behavior was obviously
wrong and also criminal but
you might argue that it's a tad overkill
to pursue her across the country and put
her on trial for four
felonies when nobody was hurt in her
outburst and the only long-term
consequences of her actions will be
suffered by the culprit herself
i mean you might argue that hours before
her arrest
gail king on cbs conducted an exclusive
multi-part interview with pansetto
now when you watch it when you watch
this interview all you can wonder is
why is this crazy woman who freaked out
about a cell phone getting so much
attention
an interview with gail king on cbs for
this
really with everything else going on in
the world right now
this is what you're devoting airtime to
and cbs isn't alone a search for mia
pancetto's name on google returns
thousands of results many of them
reporting breathlessly about every
aspect of this earth-shattering case
others offering lengthy analyses of the
cultural implications
then others like this article the new
york post reporting that mia pancetto
wears ugly outfits
here's the headline soho karen mia
pancetto mocked for wearing
trash crop top sandals and socks
well if wearing sandals and socks is a
fashion crime then you're gonna have to
lock me up too
i may not be the best best one to defend
her fashion choices nor am i interested
in but
i will say to her credit she tried to
beat the media at its own game
so here she is in that gayle king
interview
um claiming that she could not be racist
because she herself is a woman of color
and and
note the reaction to that claim here it
is listen
you might remember this video mia
poncetto approached 14 year old keon
harold jr at a new york city hotel last
month accusing him
of stealing her phone his father jazz
musician
keon harrell recorded the encounter and
accused poncetto
of racial profiling i was approaching
the the people that had been
exiting the hotel because in my mind
anybody exiting is probably the one that
might be the one that is trying to steal
my phone i admit yes
i could have approached the situation
differently or maybe not yelled at him
like that
and made him feel you know maybe some
sort of uh
inferior i wasn't racial profiling
whatsoever
i'm a woman i'm puerto rican i'm like a
woman of color i'm i'm
italian greek puerto rican you keep
saying you're puerto rican does that
mean that you can't be racist because
you're saying you're a woman of color is
that what you mean
exactly well i would disagree that
people of color can be racist
i love that exactly that's exactly what
i'm saying
and by the current rules she's exactly
right
you know i i got a defender on this one
i i don't i don't agree with the rules
um i think anybody of any race or
ethnicity can be racist
mio pancetta could be racist gayle king
could be raised if you wanted to be
anybody can your skin pigmentation does
not make you any more or less
susceptible to racism
that's not how racism works but again i
don't make the rules unfortunately
the the people who do make them have
long since clarified
that only white people can be racist
this is what critical race theory
teaches it's what those kids in school
are being indoctrinated into
power plus privilege equals racism
and only whites have power and privilege
according to this doctrine
poncetto says she isn't white it's what
she says
and by the looks of it you know it does
seems like she isn't lying
so notice how quickly critical race
theory is abandoned or exceptions and
additional qualifiers are conjured out
of thin air
just to maintain the narrative about
this woman now we find many headlines
like this one in yahoo news
mia pancetto proves proves that simply
being a person of color
isn't enough oh really it isn't
well that's the first i'm hearing that
so who is canceled today it seems
redundant to cancel pancetto who is
now facing four felonies and the
national disgrace in pariah the parents
of of the kids say
it's not enough no it's there's not
enough justice has been done
i kind of feel like it is enough and
she's a national disgrace everybody
hates her
she's got four felonies like what else
do you want
except for money from that hotel so i
would say that's probably punishment
enough given the offense
instead i'm canceling all of the people
who were so
excited to have a video like this to
prove their point
that they've made this woman famous in
the process
and i'm canceling the race hustling
vultures like sharkton who've swooped in
to get their piece of the action
doing their normal routine of course
he's canceled as well a lot of
cancellations to go around today
and that's that's how i like it it's
more efficient that way
so they're all canceled and that's going
to do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledovsky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the house impeaches president trump
again aoc unwittingly offers
insight and conservatives score a win at
the supreme court check it out in the
michael knowles show